ja grüß Gott ich bin der wiesenwirt hier
ich bin bewiesen wird es gibt keinen
schöneren Beruf als wie wird gell obwohl
immer darauf ganz schön was auf sich
nimmt also ich muss wirklich sagen
langsam Morgen immer ziffers als wäre
nett die Butter wird teurer die Milch
wird teurer alles wird teuer oder wird
doch dann ist Bier auch einmal ein
bisschen teurer werden dürfen nicht mir
reißen uns ja eh zusammen wenn ich das
rein alles rechnen würde was ich für
Kosten habe dann muss er die Maß Bier
auf dem Oktoberfest 20 € Kosten 20 ich
muss noch ein bisschen Geld verlangen
dürfen für mein Bier das ist ebenso
Unkostenbeitrag nicht ich kann doch
nicht alles Herrschinger Papa
haben ja Messi das ist auch wieder so
voll man sieht mein Herr Sohn dieser
Krippe manche kannte meinen schwarzen
Porsche immer oder ein Daimler oder ein
Lexus alle Kinder runter